trey yingst is in kiev ukraine with the
latest and trey it's been quite a day
what's the latest
yeah good evening we have heard air raid
sirens once again in the ukrainian
capital of kiev and explosions in the
distance it's not just this city though
the second largest city in ukraine
kharkiv coming under attack today from
heavy russian bombardments freedom plaza
a square in the central part of kharkiv
hit with two russian cruise missiles
killing at least six people this leading
ukrainian president velodemir zelinski
to call the event a war crime and he's
calling on the international community
to hold russia accountable and
reconsider nato alliance and the
ukrainian people take a listen to what
he had to say today
as far as a no-fly zone is concerned it
would have helped a lot
this is not about dragging nato
countries into war
the truth is everyone has long since
been dragged into war and definitely not
by ukraine but by russia
zielinski speaking today from a bunker
in the ukrainian capital of kiev much
like the civilians here he is waiting
underground or at least undercover in an
effort to stay away from the russian air
campaign those who can leave the
ukrainian capital are doing so we saw
them today at the train station some
heartbreaking scenes
a familiar scene unfolds in the
ukrainian capital lori gretzenko says
goodbye to his daughter and
granddaughter they're evacuating to the
city of la vie near the polish border
we need to leave our homes to make our
children safe i never thought it would
be like that it's not a joke but hell
like thousands of ukrainian men uri will
stay and fight as the russian invasion
continues
my family my daughter and granddaughter
are leaving i'm staying as i'm in the
territorial defense
people here are running out of time
there's a real understanding that
russian forces could surround the city
in a matter of days so the central train
station in kiev
is a major evacuation point for people
looking to go west
the city remains on edge tonight with a
curfew and place and roadblocks set up
throughout the ukrainian capital back to
you trey we're going to have some
questions for you i'll kick it off here
i just have a question about the other
another city named kershawn which is
where there was a very a lot of bravery
earlier in the week with one of the
soldiers who blew himself up to stop a
russian advance at that bridge there but
apparently the russians are in kershawn
now
yes it's an area in the southern part of
ukraine near crimea and it's significant
because it allows the russians to
continue that land bridge
into ukrainian territory we were in this
area with the ukrainian defense forces
in the southern part of the country just
about three weeks ago and it's not very
well defended it allowed russian tanks
and artillery units to move very quickly
into this part of the country but what's
significant is that if the russians
continue their advance in this part of
ukraine it will allow them to flank up
here to the capital of kiev and allow
them to attack the city from multiple
directions which would be extremely
difficult to defend
jesse waters do you want to go next sure
trey so if russian forces surround the
city
what kind of preparations are underway
inside kiev to prepare stockpiling food
stockpiling water and weapons because
after you're surrounded nothing's
getting in or out
absolutely we've seen it in recent days
the lines around the block at grocery
stores but also the lines around the
block at police stations civilians
picking up any weapons they can find
getting ready for the russian tanks and
artillery units to start rolling into
this city what we've seen interestingly
enough today is that people are using
anything they can to block the roads
there are checkpoints every single block
and if they don't have enough concrete
barriers they're pushing large objects
into the street so at one checkpoint we
saw a piano that had been dragged across
the road and put into the middle of the
street it gives you a sense of the
ukrainians and the resilience and what
they're using everything they can to
stop the russian advance
judge jeanine
you know trey we've been talking about
this 40-mile russian convoy that is
entering ukraine
why is it that no one has attacked that
convoy with a hellfire missile or some
kind of a drone with a hellfire missile
on it
the ukrainians simply don't have enough
air power to take out a convoy this
large and the international community
doesn't want to get involved at risk of
the russians
counter-attacking and then this would
trigger article 5 of nato and draw in a
lot of countries to this fight what's
significant though about this convoy it
is coming in near the antonov air base
an air base that sits just outside of
the city limits of kiev and it was a
place central to fighting when this
invasion first started but now that the
russians control this area they're
likely to start their ground invasion
and offensive into this city from the
northwest and when that happens the
ukrainians are going to be hit pretty
hard from that direction and it's part
of the reason they're hoping that
russian forces don't make a quicker
advance on the city from other
directions because they'd have to spread
out their forces and it would
significantly weaken the defense forces
here in ukraine right i understand that
it has to be you know that we don't want
to do it
from the air to the ground but
are you saying they have no hellfire
missiles no drones that doesn't have to
come from the air
they do have drones and they also have
missiles they've taken out a number of
russian units along different convoys
and they've been actually quite
successful with the anti-tank missiles
it's part of the reason one of the main
requests right now from the defense
minister in ukraine is receiving more
anti-tank missiles another significant
point has to do with the skies everyone
thought early on in this conflict that
the russians would control the skies as
their air force is nearly 10 times the
size of ukraine's but so far they
haven't the ukrainians have used air
defense systems to shoot down not only
helicopters but also fighter jets in
this battle thank you
before we go to harold i just want to
point out that there's this new video
that we are showing you on the screen
it's a very different day
today than it was yesterday with this
additional damage that you're seeing it
is unlike what we've seen in europe
since world war ii harold ford jr do you
have a question for trey i do trade very
quickly first off thanks for your
bravery and great reporting
we heard today that a second meeting
between the russians and ukrainians
either had taken place was scheduled to
take place any sense
if there's an altering in
putin's ask of ukraine or the ukrainians
led by this brave president of theirs is
willing to accept something or he's
asking for something differently uh in
light of the pressure that kiev seems to
be under this evening
there will likely be another meeting
between the russians and the ukrainians
in the coming days but what's important
to remember is that the russians often
promise things on the ground and then
act very differently with their military
we saw really a stark contrast in the
way these two sides were dressed when
they met along the border of belarus the
russians showed up in suits in thais and
the ukrainians in battle fatigues we
also got some more information from the
french because they spoke with
president putin of russia french
president emmanuel macron on the phone
with him this week and it really gave us
a sense of how unrealistic the russian
demands are they would like ukraine to
give up all of their weapons and then
recognize an area of land called crimea
that was annexed by russia back in 2014
these are both non-starters for this
entire conflict and any sort of peace
process that would come out of these
conversations brian kilmeade
well uh trey a couple of things uh
kharkiv has been under a assault it
looks like it's been uh solely
surrounded in the
city that was known to be there's a lot
of russians there they thought it was
pro-russian doesn't seem to be
there's reports out of there that
they're actually going for civilians
they've changed from taking on fighters
to aiming at civilian targets have you
heard that and how does that make you
feel knowing
that there's a 40 mile caravan
about 10 miles away from you guys with
the same intention
the russians claim they aren't targeting
civilians in ukraine they're lying they
target civilians all over the world in
syria you can see thousands of civilians
have been killed by russian strikes and
it is part of the playbook to instill
fear in the population as they move
forward with these attacks and it's
unfortunate to see
such a level of human casualties and
such a human toll taken in this conflict
so far but the reality is they are
targeting civilian areas we have not
only seen it in kharkiv the second
largest city but also here in the
capital of kiev over the weekend a
russian missile slammed into an
apartment building killing at least two
people they've shelled areas where there
are only civilians living so it is part
of this campaign and i think the concern
and it's one of the biggest concerns we
have to remember is that as president
putin slows this operation as we have
seen in recent days and he
faces this very fierce resistance he may
resort to hitting more civilian areas in
an effort to try to bring the ukrainians
to their knees and the reality is they
say they will fight back no matter what
it's part of the reason you've seen
velodemir zelinski the ukrainian leader
try to galvanize the civilian population
and the army at the same time because he
understands this will be a fierce and
bloody battle and when a convoy that's
40 miles long ultimately makes it to
this capital city of nearly 3 million
people it will be bloody urban warfare
make no mistake about that there will be
a lot of deaths and it's an extremely
difficult situation for the ukrainian
people
trey yings stay safe for us we'll see
you later this evening we appreciate it
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now